congresswoman Gabbard joins us tonight
congressman thanks so much for coming on
so what do you make of this I mean you
must have the television on you walk
through an airport and you're a captive
to CNN for a minute and you hear people
say there are no women in the race and
they're thinking well I'm in the race
right here what do you make of I I I'm
here yeah yeah no you're right it's
happened more than once where yes
walking through airports or happen to
see a television on and it is it is
actually a disservice to the voters
really is is what's happening here is
they're disrespecting the voters in this
country and their ability to make the
best informed decision about who they
would like to see move forward as a
Democratic nominee and and it really
begs the question why are they doing
this why is the political elite in
Washington their corporate media
partners why are they continuing to try
to erase my candidacy to try to stop
voters from hearing the message that I'm
continuing to bring to the forefront
that began the very first day that I
that I announced my candidacy for
president this attempt to black out or
smear my campaign my character my
candidacy it's really not a mystery why
I'm running for president is to bring
about a sea change in our foreign policy
a sea change that says we will end these
wasteful regime change wars stop going
around the world trying to be the
world's police toppling dictators work
to end this new Cold War and nuclear
arms race all of which are not making us
any safer and instead redirect our
taxpayer dollars actually towards
serving the needs of the American people
here at home things like dealing with
the coronavirus things like investing in
in education and in health care
affordable housing there's such urgent
needs that people have this is the
change that I seek to bring about it's
not a mystery this is why I'm running
for president the American people
deserve to know why those in power don't
want them to hear this message it's it
was meeting with Assad which I thought
was great I mean I don't you know Saad
whatever I'm not endorsing Assad but he
did protect religious minorities
including Christians I'm a Christian
Christian leaders in the region say that
you have a right to make that point they
haven't let you make that point or any
point they just dismiss you because
of that we know how much time but I'm
just like what is that about it's
bizarre it is it is a dangerous
situation that we are in that so many
people here in Washington who are part
of this powerful elite who have this
stranglehold over the foreign policy
establishment are so afraid of diplomacy
and they cast out people like me who are
calling for a foreign policy focused on
cooperation and diplomacy rather than
confrontation as something weird or
batters to be suspicious of when you
look at so many leaders throughout our
country's history who have made those
tough decisions to exercise diplomacy to
prevent our country from unnecessarily
going to war well exactly it was brave
and you should be rewarded for bravery
but you've been vilified congresswoman
Gabbard thank so much for joining us I
appreciate you